returning to Ukraine now thousands of
people have been forced to flee from
their homes after a dam collapsed in the
russian-held Ukraine part of Ukraine Dr
alira halushka co-founder of
International Center for Ukrainian
Victory Is With Us now good morning
thank you for joining us what do you
know about the latest situation as far
as the dam is concerned well the
situation is very critical because
that's a very big humanitarian
catastrophe and what regards the
ukrainian-controlled governmental
controlled towns and Villages there is
evacuation we know that this is not
happening from the Russian occupied
Parts because the occupation
Administration simply do not care we
also know that the level of water will
continue to grow for the next couple of
days and after that it will go down
Russia says it wasn't ours well they
always say it wasn't us they even do not
expect accept that they are Waging
full-scale War they call it special
military operation that this is their
modus operandi why would they do this
this is their military tactics quote
scorched Earth if they understand that
Ukrainian counter-offensive is coming
they would want to try and stop it by
all of the means or if they are going to
retreat they will simply leave
absolutely destroyed Earth
um as far as this area is concerned
um it has been under Russian control
hasn't it for many years now at the dam
the area around it because for one year
okay so the Donetsk area
Donetsk yes for nine years okay and as
far as this area is concerned as you say
it the the water will go down uh within
the next three days or so what's going
to happen
um to the people then and when are we
seeing the counter-offensive that we've
heard so much about
um well it's also very important that
the counter offensive depends on the
space
pace and speed of the military
assistance because we have seen that
there was a lot of commitments for the
tanks for the
um
artillery pieces and ammunition but
there is certain time lack in between
the political commitment and their
actual arrival on the battlefield so uh
obviously it's very important to listen
to what the Ukrainian authorities are
saying with regards to how Ukrainian
Army is supplied but it is also very
important to leave Ukrainian military
with enough time to get prepared because
if we do not have if we start
counter-offensive not being supplied
with enough of the military equipment
that would cost us a lot with regards to
human lives yeah the reason I ask is
there's a suggestion that the Russians
have done this if it was the Russians in
order to Stave off that military
offensive in other words the Russians
think that it's um almost upon them
well the Russians did this to to the dam
and yes they definitely tried to stop
counter-offensive doing that but I don't
think that they will be successful
some have suggested that this is a war
crime how would you describe it I would
describe that this is the attempted use
of the weapon of mass destruction
because there are around 16
000 of people who are in a very high
risk of the floods
and there is very big attack on
Ukraine's agriculture because that there
were
the channels of supplying waters for the
farms and Fields
that also puts in Risk the Buddhism
nuclear power plant it is not yet
um it doesn't have a direct implications
yet but again the situation is evolving
and we are we need to monitor that and
given that nuclear power plant uh huge
crime against
environment Echo site obviously these
are all war crimes okay um thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you very much thank you